last season we had a lot of fun battle
testing a GoPro camera without its case
AKA naked and some of you weren't so
happy about that little one just to put
the GoPros clothes back on because folks
a real class acts so now we're going to
pit a fully clothed GoPro against two of
its biggest competitors to see which
action cam is truly the toughest
GoPro currently dominates the actioncam
market but now Sony and contour are
trying to get in on the action with some
competitive cheaper cameras they may do
well underwater but let's see how these
cams stack up against cold hard
Travie t alright action cams these
things are meant to take some damage
roll action
that one flat in the case make it did
now check to see which ones are still
recording after that the contour not
recording sony also not looking good
gopro still recording alright let's
check the cards to see if the footage
actor works ryan our di t you've checked
the card to have the results of these
cameras I do what's the result for the
contour and the action cam the files
from the actual impacts seemed corrupted
gonna play them please go Suresh out so
sad fifteen feet it's not even that hard
of an impact when they're encased with
the GoPro the file from the drop dead
place some stuttering but I don't know
if that's from the GoPro itself or just
here every trouble at playback you know
I think that our action cams right I'm
disappointed didn't take a lot of action
I guess there's a reason GoPros number
one
here on Battle Damage just because of
product wins doesn't mean we're done
with it which is why I'm about to spike
this GoPro like a football I believe in
you Justin feed
Oh how does it look is it still
recording no it's not the lights on it
says 49 stuck on number
I know it's frozen on the back too so
this is so cool
it's the steel plating that's like
melted I've never seen this on yo bro
you've never spiked your GoPro and seen
this I don't know this footage is still
gonna work that's the real question
okay it's shame save time for shame time
roll action
big breakdancing move take a look
at the bottom of that safe oh yeah that
thing did a spin oh my gosh look at this
I think the contract is like the brunt
of it cuz he is taller but you get
that's what you get for being tall so
this thing is definitely broken but yeah
put up a fight well it looks like the
GoPro is the toughest but what do you
think of our results let us know down
there in the comments is that cruel of
us to make our cameras film other
cameras being destroyed
no Justin cameras don't feel feelings
you're right